[Musique]
l'écologie vous avez dû voir dans les
actualités les nombreux appels des
scientifiques comme un communiqué signé
par quinze mille d'entre eux qui tirent
la sonnette d'alarmé sur ce que l'on
fait subir à la terre ces appels se
multiplient la plupart disant que c'est
déjà trop tard que le point de non
retour et déjà tu ces communications
sont primordiales et je suis signataire
de certaines d'entre elles mais
aujourd'hui je vais vous partagez
l'autre côté ce côté qui essaient de
faire des efforts petit pas par petit
pas celui de l'industrie lourde
j'ai toujours eu une affinité avec la
nature a apprécié sa beauté le sentiment
de liberté qu'elle procure
et ce depuis mon plus jeune âge bon j'ai
grandi en auvergne aussi on va dire que
je n'avais pas trop le choix et ça n'a
pas trop changé maintenant à part que je
suis sûrement un peu plus rapide entre
les deux j'ai fait des études et comme
tout le monde j'ai essayé de trouver la
voie que j'ai trouvé ma voie et je me
suis lancé dans le domaine qui paraît le
plus proche des préoccupations
environnementales la chimie faut avouer
que c'est moi ou chimie il fait peur et
il ne fait pas vraiment penser à la
nature non plus mais la chimie c'est
aussi tout le progrès tout le confort de
la vie moderne
tout ce que nous utilisons chaque jour
et basés de près ou de loin à de la
chine du coup je me suis lancé dans le
domaine qui paraît une nouvelle fois le
plus proche avec la nature le domaine
des polymères
je vois que certains ne savent pas ce
que c'est mais je vois aussi que
certains font la grimace
car oui les polymères comprennent les
plastiques mais pas que là par
définition un polymère est un
enchaînement de molécules qui
s'imbriquent les unes avec les autres
un peu comme le ferait des lego il
existe donc des polymères de toutes
sortes et certains qui sont naturels en
plus tout à l'heure quand vous sortirez
du bâtiment je vous invite à regarder
vos pieds
par chance vous verrez peut-être de
l'herbe cette herbe à halle est composé
à 20% d'un polymère la cellulose qui
elle même est composé de molécules de
glucose
alors vous me direz pourquoi ne pas
utiliser les polymères qui sont déjà
présents dans la nature on le fait déjà
avec la cellulose par exemple pour le
papier mais dès que le mot faire des
matériaux plus résistants
cela devient vite compliqué et c'est mon
objectif je veux créer le polymère qui
volera dans les fusées de demain et qui
aura un impact minimum sur
l'environnement
mesdames et messieurs je vous souhaite
la bienvenue à bord d' numéro un à
destination de la terre et en provenance
de mars bien vouloir attachez vos
ceintures en vue de la rentrée
atmosphérique et vous souhaite un
agréable voyage notre vitesse est
actuellement 28 autres par heure et la
température extérieure et 2 celsius
vous entendrez peut-être cela dans
quelques dizaines d'années
mais si vous avez bien écouter le
commandant de bord ça chauffe l'adorent
2000 degrés celsius
la navette a intérêt à être bien protégé
sinon vous verrez une belle étoile
filante heureusement il ya des matériaux
spécialement conçu pour ça dans
l'aérospatiale le bouclier thermique
vous pouvez le voir comme une grosse
carapace
je vous passe les détails sur toute sa
composition mais j'aimerais que vous
reteniez une chose dedans il ya ce que
l'on appelle une résine ablative et
c'est sur ce composé
la résine ablative que je cherche
est actuellement produite à partir de
composés qui sont cancérigènes que je
cherche à remplacer par un polymères
bio-sourcés c'est à dire issus de
ressources renouvelables et l'aspect
biosourcés n'est pas le seul à prendre
en compte pour créer un polymère qui a
un impact minimum sur l'environnement
ce serait dommage de créer un polymère
issu à 100 % de ressources renouvelables
mais qui soit toxique
et si je vous parle de ça ce n'est pas
par hasard
c'est ce qui m'est malheureusement
arriver dans mes recherches bon le bon
côté c'est que je peux me vanter d'avoir
créé un poison biosourcés mais je vous
assure c'est un vrai casse tête car il
faut que je crée une molécule qui soit
capable de réagir sur elle même pour
former le polymère mais qui ne soit pas
réactif sur les êtres vivants
c'est un peu comme si vous me demandiez
de créer un pesticide qui ne soit pas
dangereux pour l'homme et le côté de
toxique n'est pas le seul aspect à
prendre en compte pour créer un matériau
vraiment durable il y en a plein
d'autres comme la consommation
énergétique ou la génération déchets et
toutes ces questions me font presque
oublier le plus important est ce que le
polymère il fera bien son boulot car si
je ne suis même pas capable de protéger
une mouche je serai bien content avec
mon polymère propre mais bon imaginons
que j'arrive à développer le polymère il
faudra vingt ans pour qu'il se
concrétise en produits industriels 20
ans vous pensez donc que les entreprises
vont se lancer dans cette croisade juste
parce qu'une molécule est suspecté
d'être cancérigène
alors qu'ils ont quelque chose qui
marche très bien depuis les années 50
c'est comme si il ya une dizaine
d'années je m'étais dit je soupçonne ma
voiture diesel de rejeter beaucoup de
microparticules je vais changer pour une
voiture électrique
elle coûte trois fois plus cher je ne
peux pas faire de longues distances avec
et je ne nie même la recharge est
partout entre nous jamais je n'aurais
changé de voiture
mais la question que ça amène c'est
plutôt qu'est-ce qui aurait fait que je
change de voiture à l'époque deux choses
si je n'ai pas le choix car les
véhicules diesel deviennent interdits ou
si le fait la deuxième
si le fait d'avoir un véhicule
eq trick me fait gagner de l'argent par
rapport à un véhicule diesel et c'est
exactement la même chose avec une
entreprise le si je n'ai pas le choix
c'est ce qu'il se passe en ce moment
dans l'industrie chimique avec le
règlement reach qui a été mis en place
par l'union européenne
le but contrôler et réguler les produits
chimiques qui circulent en europe
l'efficacité 22000 molécules enregistré
48 molécules avec des restrictions si
importantes qu'elles sont quasiment
interdite 534 molécules restreinte dans
leur utilisation et au moins un doctorat
de créer le mien car oui l'écologie
créer de l'emploi et pour le côté me
fait gagner de l'argent c'est nous qui
orientons de marché
si la demande diminue la production ne
sera plus rentable pour l'entreprise
elle n'aura d'autre choix que de se
réorienter sur ce que nous recherchons
comment soit supprimé un produit soit
trouver des alternatives qui nous
conviennent il ya un exemple que l'on
peut facilement prendre la vie de tous
les jours les sacs plastique à usage
unique
ils sont maintenant interdits depuis
plusieurs années en france mais vous
pouvez toujours croiser des sacs à base
d'amidon qui sont bio sourcés et
biodégradable parce qu'ils viennent
différentes biosourcés qui signifie
issus de ressources renouvelables et
biodégradable qui signifie se dégradant
la note dans la nature mais at on
réellement besoin de sacs plastiques ne
suffirait-il pas d'utiliser des sacs en
tissu lavable par exemple je pense que
c'est un raisonnement que l'on devrait
avoir pour tous les matériaux en at on
réellement besoin
non donc on s'en sépare est-ce vital et
polluants oui donc trouvons des
alternatives mais il est vrai que pour
des utilisations plus techniques comme
dans l'aérospatiale il est beaucoup plus
dur de trouver des solutions qui
tiennent la route facilement et cela
coûte très cher il est donc nécessaire
que l' impulsion soit donnée par des
organismes plus puissants comme l'union
européenne vous vous souvenez du
règlement reach
il n'est pas arrivé en claquant des
doigts il a fallu dix ans pour le mettre
en place
cela me fait penser que ça fait
maintenant un an et demi que j'ai
commencé à travailler et donc le premier
travail que j'ai effectué et de
rechercher des solutions durables pour
l'industrie lourde
au tout début je me disais qu'il devait
déjà existé plein de choses que j'allais
juste apporter quelques briques sur un
mur qui est déjà bien entamée mais en
fait pas du tout la recherche actuelle
en est seulement à poser des fondations
qui soit solide et si vous avez bien
suivi
vous savez maintenant que le
développement d'un matériau est long il
est donc nécessaire de prendre des
décisions globales a rapidement à ce
titre vous avez déjà entendu parler du
trou dans la couche d'ozone
la semaine dernière j'ai discuté avec un
doctorant australien et il m'a dit que
le soleil est beaucoup plus puissant
chez lui je me suis demandé pourquoi on
a tous le même soleil non la réponse se
trouve dans l'épaisseur de la couche
d'ozone comme elle a été attaquée elle
est plus fine et il ya plus de rayons
ultraviolets qui pénètre à l'intérieur
résultat deux australiens sur trois
développent un cancer de la peau au
cours de leur vie deux tiers de la
population
heureusement il y à des mesures ont été
prises aujourd'hui pour éviter la
destruction totale de la couche d'ozone
mais ce n'a pas été facile les
scientifiques ont alerté dès 1973 que
les composés à base de gaz les gaz à
base de composés chlorés et fluorés
présent dans les réfrigérateurs sont
responsables du trou dans la couche
d'ozone
il a fallu attendre 1987 pour leur
interdiction 14 ans et il a fallu encore
attendre sept ans de plus pour voir leur
disparition totale des chaînes de
production
en tout 21 ans auront été nécessaires
pour supprimer les substances qui creuse
la seule protection que nous offre la
terre contre les rayonnements
ultraviolets ceci est l'exemple qu'il
faut également prendre des décisions
internationales
j'aimerais maintenant vous abordez une
dernière idée arrive qu'il tient à coeur
ce n'est pas parce que je fais un
doctorat dans l'aérospatiale que je
cherche à comprendre le monde qui nous
entoure
plutôt parce que je cherche à le
comprendre que j'en suis venu à faire ce
dr aujourd'hui je vous ai parlé du trou
dans la couche d'ozone
c'est très loin de mon sujet de
recherche portant sur les polymères
bio-sourcés c'est la curiosité qui me
pousse à comprendre les informations qui
me parviennent mais aujourd'hui avec
toutes les données qui arrive il est
parfois difficile de démêler le vrai du
faux
et pour ça j'utilise quelque chose que
je fais tous les jours dans mes
recherches je croise les informations et
je vérifie les sources
quelle est la légitimité d'une étude
stipulant la non toxicité d'un produit
chimique financé par l'entreprise qui le
produit il faut rester vigilant sur la
provenance de l'information tout est une
question de perspective
et en parlant de perspectives il y a
quelque chose qui m'a frappé en tant que
chercheur dans mon domaine les polymères
je m'intéresse à toutes les échelles au
niveau nanoscopique là où on observe les
atomes au niveau microscopique là où on
voit les bactéries et au niveau
macroscopique ce que l'on voit à la
ligne ce qui est incroyable c'est que la
moindre modification que je fais au
niveau nanoscopique sur les atomes
modifie visuellement l'aspect du
polymère au niveau macroscopique et
c'est tout est connecté et c'est
exactement la même chose pour la terre
des plus petits micro-organismes
jusqu'aux grands phénomènes terrestres
ce sont ces micro organismes qui nous
permette d'exister aujourd'hui par leurs
milliards de petites actions combinées
alors si nous voulons conserver la terre
comme maison pour l'humanité nous
pouvons agir comme ces milliards de
micro organismes par des petites actions
à toutes les échelles et pour tous ceux
qui disent que les petites actions ne
servent à rien ce ne sont pas les
dinosaures qui ont sauvé la vie après
l'extinction de masse
merci
[Applaudissements]